and more on Stuart's report online of
course uh do check that out sky news.com
now Russia has accused Ukraine of trying
to assassinate Vladimir Putin in a drone
attack on the Kremlin an allegation Kiev
has denied it's spawned conspiracy
theories about who did it even whether
Russia could have carried out the attack
themselves what does the former deputy
chief of the defense staff so Simon Mayo
think so Simon it's great to see you
thanks for joining us okay good morning
who do you think might be responsible uh
you've come up perfectly plausible a
plausible conspiracy theories that
either side could have done it the
balance of expectation I would have
thought is that it benefits Putin at
this stage the war is going very badly
in Ukraine
um particularly on the military side the
ukrainians of course are about to launch
some form of counter-offensive you know
in the capitals of Europe in Washington
NATO they'll they'll know more about
that and of course puta's got to stand
on the uh you know outside the Kremlin
next Tuesday with a victory parade going
on
um equally you may want to do another
mobilization but it's a sort of
admission of weakness in order to
generate I suspect a narrative that
allows him to up the anti in Ukraine
yeah wonder if you could explain that in
a bit more detail about what's in it for
both sides what what are the positives
and negatives to both sides yeah well I
don't see much upside for zielinski
other than you know it's great for
morale if you're in Kiev or you're in
the Ukrainian Armed Forces
to see the sort of you know
the heart of the evil Empires they would
see it quite quite rightly and
justifiably being attacked being
attacked but for zelinski who's played a
very very tough set of cards extremely
well in terms of keeping Western support
I don't think the Americans or the NATO
allies would particularly what wish to
be associated with the Ukraine attacking
the Kremlin the heart of Moscow so
although I can see that being short-term
morale boost of the ukrainians I think
the long-term strategic it would be too
bad but for Putin I think with as I say
the war game badly a counter-offensive
coming the feeling that you need to say
to the Russian people why we continue to
need to make the sacrifice look at these
terrorists they're trying to attack me
personally
um I need to you know turn this into an
even greater National effort to kill
zelenski crush the ukrainians denarcify
it feeds into that sort of narrative and
that seems more plausible to me than the
benefits that zielinski could do in in
operating that and and the Russians have
form on this without without doubt you
know they've cried wolf often and it was
one of the reasons they were able to
launch the offense in chechnya you know
they staged a series of bomb attacks
across Moscow it's whipped everybody up
into some sort of
frenzy that the chechens were
responsible and then use that to launch
their offensive Way Way Back In Putin's
time suggestions that President zelensky
could be more vulnerable as a result I
went to Instagram earlier on in the year
and you know we talked then about the
fact that there are attempts on his life
all the time absolutely and then you'll
remember okay the the the the original
Russian plan was the capital kill
zelenski in the first you know 72 hours
of the uh the invasion of you I really
did and they nearly did and of course if
things had gone
well for them they they would have
without doubt and uh failure to kill
zelenski then was really you know a
major blow in terms of allowing people
to Rally around Ukraine and for the West
to see there was a you know there was a
spokesman and a leader there so I don't
think they have remotely given up the
idea that they might wish to kill
zelenski and giving themselves an excuse
to say well you had an attack on Putin
even though it was like you know
it was an attack on the roof of the
Senate and freedom wasn't even there
yeah yeah I mean the kill team's just a
few hundred meters away from zelenski at
the start but you will be on Tuesday
bristles around him now well he just
sort of you know it's also a bit
humiliating for the Russians are
supposed to have the you know the most
sophisticated air defense system around
the Kremlin to to have an attack on the
seat of Russian power so you'll be
reporting on there's a no doubt um you
know the Russian Victory Parade on
Tuesday we will
um so it'll be interesting to see the
context where we've got on that and what
the uh what the uh the Russians have
done over the over the weekend and of
course in certain stages the ukrainians
will will launch the you know the
counterfeit which takes me on to my next
question where do you think we are
without the um Ambassador sat where you
are the to the UK
um from Ukraine is that where you are um
earlier on in the week and he was saying
we're not going to tell you obviously of
course they're not going to tell us but
he did say they've got 98 of the
hardware that they have been promised
from the West yes uh and they've been
training very hard and they're far
response Learners and as you say they're
re-equipped it is a war of material
um even as a lead skill I think anybody
says we're not as I might say well
equipped as the Russians but in terms of
depth of material particularly artillery
ammunition they probably know they have
limitations but their their tails are
definitely up one we've thought of you
were a Russian soldier dug in some way
you'd you'd be getting very nervous so
it will be an issue of morale and a
battle of wills as Wars always are
um and as I've said to a number of
people your history is littered with the
Russian military collapsing leading to
major political change in in Russia and
that would be the worry but it it could
be a bit of a One-Shot a One-Shot effort
from the ukrainians so it needs to
succeed for zielinski to keep NATO and
the Americans and the west and public
opinion behind Ukraine's efforts and not
try and force them into a negotiated
solution they will want to launch this
offensive and it needs to be successful
not necessarily to throw the you know
the Russians out of the donbass or the
Crimea but set the conditions where it's
quite clearly that the the Russians are
on the back foot and they have very
little more to gain by continuing to to
invest in this War I was speaking to to
one of your former colleagues yesterday
and said to him that War's history would
tell us are often won in the Airy
disagree because he was he was a soldier
but you know they do want fighter jets
from the West uh as as it stands we're
not sending them
yes and people have sort of looked at
you know where they set the bar of
Western support to the Ukraine
um some people say artificially given it
as a war there's no but if you are on on
the ground
um air power sets the conditions for
your success all defends it gives you
room to maneuver and that's undoubtedly
what the uh the ukrainians need they
need to have a lot of deception they
need to hit the Russians where they're
weak and they need the capacity to
support that maneuver by owning the
airspace so the lack of an Air Force is
or the lack of an air capability is is
significant for the ukrainians it's not
something you can deliver fast I think
that point was made last year
um tanks are easier artillery easy of
ground maneuver easier to train people
up to fly a jet they haven't flown on
before it's not the flying it's the
integration of the weapon system so
important would not make any difference
for in the time frame we're talking
about this offensive unless NATO a NATO
air power itself has been used but just
took thought on that before I let you go
to Simon if I may I mean I was reading
at the weekend that the Ukrainian Air
Force fighter jets are intact because
they were taken out of the country just
before the war started so why can't they
be used
well I suppose they could I I would not
be qualified to answer that question but
I do remember the
um the Iraqi Air Force left Iraq
um before the before the first Gulf War
disappeared into Iran that was never
seen again I'd be very surprised if it's
sitting outside I know they've had
attrition they've been they've been in
air combat they've had you know aircraft
destroyed on the ground in the early
stages I suspect I can only assume the
the issue is spare parts and Munitions
uh trained fighter pilots as well but uh
there's not my not my area of expertise
well you've shared lots of other
expertise with us this morning for which
we are eternally grateful to Simon thank
you for joining us thank you very much